I was a registered Democrat I bought a
Clinton and I voted right and then I
went in the middle and I'm independent
libertarian I voted fire me Carter
I am you voted for Jimmy Libya so I
stopped being it that's why I'm in
America if there was no Jimmy Carter I'd
still be in Iran I wouldn't be in
America if there wasn't for Jimmy Carter
I'd probably still be in Iran living
there doing something else with the ship
but you would be doing well it would be
a much freer country to be in e Rondon
the Iran under the Shah of course it was
an infinitely morally superior no doubt
economically and socially no doubt about
it no doubt about it him his son and I
had a conversation about it in DC the
day I was with Ted Cruz
so okay fair enough so let's let's
finalize this topic here this is my
processing and I'm really like I really
want to know your answer like honestly I
sincerely want to know your answer on
this and I'm not trying to get one s or
another side how you having met so many
different people on both side Chris
Matthews is not stupid okay Rachel
Maddow is not dumb Elizabeth Warren is
not dumb now they may be a little bit
sensational there are very few dumpee
that's the point that dumb doesn't mean
anything educated does it mean smart
doesn't mean the number of uh smart
people who supported communists or
nothing is in the millions but fair
enough they go to the left and if you
talk about values and principles and all
of that there's a lot on the left
there's no wisdom on the left there are
a lot of say that I you can say that you
seriously think they're lies I know it I
don't say it I know it I lived it I went
to Columbia my professors were brilliant
and had almost no wisdom they taught me
that men and women are basically the
same you can be brilliant and believe
that but you can't be wise and believe
that the difference between men and
women is huge so you're saying the left
is smart the writers wise yes
you really saying yes that's exactly the
people the ideas that's correct
wisdom is there are live there are wise
liberals too but there was no wisdom on
the left the left is a nihilistic
destructive force in every society very
much left for it has ruined our
universities it has ruined our arts it
has ruined our high schools everything
it's ruining football I'm a bit
left touches it ruins okay so let's do
this just just so just so we we are we
are clear why don't you define left and
liberal let's not a difference after
exam please what is that was simplify
simplify in a way where sixth-grader
cannot I do by the way I believe I can I
believe it's our obligation to make
things as simple not simplistic as
possible example liberalism believes in
that race is meaningless that character
is everything and skin color is nothing
the left believes that character is much
less significant than skin color the
left the left believes in segregation
racially liberals believe in integration
racially a liberal is opposed to a black
dorm a liberal is opposed to a black
graduation at our vered a leftist is for
it they have nothing in common the only
thing that the left and the and the
unliberated common they have two things
belief in big government and hatred of
the right that is the only thing that
left ISM and liberalism have in common
okay so tell me who is a liberal and
who's a left somebody somebody that
people know name right I gave you Alan
Dershowitz he's a classic liberal okay
professor or Harvard will also voted for
Obama and probably Woodrow typically
noted for Clint fair enough that is
correct
who else would be a liberal okay this
there are many my whole family which
people don't know obviously publicly
there are very few public liberals today
this is a tragedy publicly the
Democratic Party which was once liberal
is now left Daniel Patrick Moynihan
these are names that will not be known
to most of your viewers senator from New
York major intellectual Democrat he was
the man who alerted the country to the
crisis of the absence of the black
father and what was he called by the
left a racist but you could say it as a
Democrat and still be elected senator
from New York not today
a Democrat who said that the biggest
problem in black life is not racism it
is absence of father's will could not be
elected dog catcher in New York
and who would you say as a left you say
Maddow Cooper they're all yes yes so
would you put let me ask you would you
put progressive philosophies in the left
or could progressive be left and liberal
progressive is a larger term for both
liberals and leftists are you saying it
okay fair enough
well then that kind of redefines when I
use the word left on where your
frustration comes with that because left
maybe they start liberal do you think
it's a good thing moral thing a liberal
thing to have a black dorm ask them that
if they say yes then then ice then I say
then you are a leftist because
liberalism was opposed to racially based
dormitories
[Music]